lawyers for the family of Harry Dunne
are now targeting the White House in the
death of the 19 year old in England the
family tells CBS News they are pursuing
a civil suit against the Trump
administration as well as Ansah coulis
she is the wife of an American official
and was involved in that car crash that
killed Dunn MTS tyub has been closely
following the case he's in London MTS
why is the family chosen to do this good
morning well it's a step Harry Dunn's
family says they hope they would never
have to take nearly three months after
he was killed in a head-on collision
that an cyclists admits to causing
they're suing not only her but also the
Trump administration here's what Harry's
stepsister Larina harbor told CBS News
about why they're taking this to court
in simple words get her back on the
plane to the UK Donald Trump has the
authorities to do that and I can't
understand why they're not you know
she's a mom of three children what
example is this setting to her three
children and mum you know a mum to a
five-year-old how do you explain you
know what's what's going on to them and
why is she hiding it it just seems wrong
I don't understand why when something
seems so simple to us
circuses immunity is of course an
extremely complex issue one that reached
the highest levels of government here in
the UK and that led Harry Dunn's parents
all the way to the White House where
they say they were shocked when
President Trump asked them to meet with
an soukous who was in an adjoining room
now they declined that meeting saying
they'd only meet with her in the UK and
in the presence of counsellors that of
course still hasn't happened and so the
family is now pursuing a civil case in
the u.s. where they will accuse the
administration of and I quote here
lawless misconduct and will also be
seeking damages now we've reached out to
sakulos lawyers and are still waiting
for a reply but this legal battle is
really just the latest chapter in what
can only be described as an
extraordinary campaign led by Harry
Dunn's parents a campaign for justice
that isn't over again yeah it's
certainly continuing remember when they
were here thank you very much empty
house when they
here at the table they said if there had
just been an apology from the very
beginning yes this would not have turned
into an international incident they said
in the beginning they didn't I don't
know what they want now but they
certainly weren't asking for prison time
because they said she's a mother they
don't want to take a mother from their
children they just wanted to face to
face to know that she was sorry and had
some interesting they've chosen to sue
the White House yeah that's quite a step
yeah they were taking another to another
level another level